keanu reeves is one of the world's most
beloved actors known for his fantastic
work in action movies like the matrix
and the john wick series though his life
has had its fair share of tragedies and
hardships that made him into the man he
is today
the emotional gut punches started at a
very young age for keanu reeves he was
just a three-year-old kid when his
father samuel reeves abandoned the
family
leaving his wife patricia to raise their
two children alone predictably he and
keanu's relationship has devolved since
then from rocky to completely
non-existent
in the 90s samuel was arrested for
possession of cocaine and heroin and
received a 10-year jail sentence
he's been out for a good while but his
relationship with his son never
recovered
both men have commented on their falling
out in the years since piano told
rolling stone in 2000
the story with me and my dad's pretty
heavy it's full of pain and woe and
[ __ ] loss and all that
clearly despite the fact that the two
men haven't spoken in years the pain
that lingers between them endures
given how young keanu was when his
father left the family that's a whole
lot of time he's had to spend dealing
with difficult feelings toward his
father for his part samuel told the
mirror piano's made it clear that he
wants nothing to do with me he went on
to add
i'm embarrassed by it all piano said my
life was tragic and oh boy does that
hurt
sad yeah i never figured things would
end up this way but he'll always be my
boy
reeves newly single mother patricia move
frequently from state to state
and marriage to marriage though there's
a lot of love there this sort of
constant upheaval is hard for anyone to
deal with let alone a kid
after reeves father left patricia took
the little clan from australia to new
york city
once settled in the big apple she met
and married broadway director paul aaron
in 1970 the couple moved to toronto
shortly after
sadly the romance didn't last but
happily enough aaron remained friendly
with reeves often giving him career
advice and helping him secure some early
acting jobs
the reeves family remained in the
yorkville neighborhood of toronto
throughout much of the 1970s and into
the following decade in 1976 patricia
married rock music promoter robert
miller but they unfortunately split in
1980.
her next marriage the hairdresser jack
bond lasted until 1994 by which time
reeves had become an established force
in hollywood
as a kid reeves struggled academically
attending four separate high schools in
total he never did earn his diploma and
never pursued higher education are you
going to graduate
graduate
reeves was in fact expelled from one of
his many schools as he told the daily
mail in 2008
it was difficult i went to four
different high schools in five years i
was okay academically good at english
and creative writing i was on the chess
team he added some reasons for the
problems including the size of the
school and numerous conflicts with
students and staff
saying i was one of those why kids i
asked too many questions about
everything
i couldn't stop even if it got me into
trouble i wanted my autonomy and if you
wanted to impose something on me then
you and i would have a problem
still he took the expulsion hard saying
it's a terrible letter to receive saying
you can't come back to school next year
getting asked to leave was very
upsetting in the end though it inspired
him to get serious about acting
by the late 80s keanu reeves was already
landing some major enviable roles most
notably in the legendary goofball buddy
comedy bill and ted's excellent
adventure
a few years later he embraced mature
films like 1990s i love you
to death and the following years my own
private idaho a drama about two street
hustler friends who embark on a journey
of self-discovery
reeves became fast friends with his
co-star in those two films river phoenix
phoenix was on a similar career
trajectory to reeves at the time having
broken into serious roles in the late
80s
unfortunately as is often the case with
young celebrities phoenix struggled with
the pressures of fame and ultimately
turned to drugs
on october 31 1993 tragedy struck when
phoenix collapsed outside los angeles
viper room
nightclub and died hours later at the
age of 23. the tragedy stunned hollywood
and reeves in particular as reeves told
the guardian in 2019
phoenix was definitely one of my closest
friends from that era who shared an
artistic sensibility river was just so
down to earth spiritual and a unique
artist yeah i miss him
by the late 90s keanu had broken out of
rising star status and become a bonafide
leading man
this happened largely on the backs of
1994's speed in which he played a young
cop trapped on a bus that's set to blow
if it travels slower than 50 miles per
hour
in 1999's the matrix in which he played
a man who discovers the world around him
as a simulation
it was around this time that he met and
fell in love with jennifer syme an
actress and personal assistant
before long jennifer was pregnant
however shortly before christmas 1999
syme noticed she hadn't felt movement
from the baby in days the two rushed to
the hospital where ultrasound tests
revealed the worst case scenario was
indeed true
sime delivered their stillborn daughter
eva archer syme reeves on december
24th 1999. understandably this loss
devastated both parents
as an anonymous friend told the globe in
2000 he really had his heart set on
becoming the dad
instead he and jennifer are undergoing
grief counseling to try and help them
cope with their anguish the loss of a
child is one of the most intense
tragedies a person can endure inevitably
it takes a massive toll on relationships
especially the one between the child's
parents this was very much the case with
keanu reeves and jennifer sein
sadly but very much understandably the
couple split a few weeks after laying
their daughter to rest
in january 2000. despite this reeves and
sein remained close after the breakup
on april 1st 2001 reeves met simon at
san francisco's crepes on coal
a popular brunch spot according to
people according to the sun she attended
a party at the home of marilyn manson
that evening
for reasons unknown after being dropped
off at her own home she left again
this time in her own vehicle shortly
after six am sime's car slammed into a
trio of parked cars she wasn't wearing a
seatbelt and was thrown from the vehicle
she died instantly the tragedies of
losing his child and former partner
changed reeves forever years later the
grief still lay heavily upon him
reeves told parade in 2006 grief changes
shape but it never ends
people have a misconception that you can
deal with it and say it's gone and i'm
better
they're wrong when the people you love
are gone you're alone
keanu reeves should have been enjoying
the peak of his acting career in the
late 90s and early aughts
however the nearly back-to-back losses
he endured during this period cast a
shadow over just about everything he did
on top of that his younger sister kim
had been fighting leukemia since 1991.
this long battle with cancer took an
enormous toll luckily she had the
support of her loved ones including her
big brother
according to a 1999 article in
australia's woman's day
reeves supported her through the years
following her diagnosis sending flowers
and special messages to a sick sister at
least once a week
reeve said i love kim she's so brave and
i want the very best for her you can
star and hit movies but that's nothing
compared to going through what kim's
been through
fortunately for everyone involved kim
reeves went into remission in 1999
as years went on reeves began taking on
more serious roles
the critics could be merciless now we'll
admit his attempt at an english accent
in 1992's bram stoker's dracula
is not great i doubted everything
even my mind i was impotent with fear
i know but it and other reeves
performances didn't merit the tidal wave
of mockery the actor soon faced
though the first matrix movie was a hit
the subsequent two were not as beloved
critics and fans alike began attacking
what they saw as reeves wooden
underperformance as protagonist neo
in his defense most of the main
characters in the matrix franchise have
the same deadpan expression no matter
what's happening
but while hugo weaving gets to cackle
and snarl as the villainous agent smith
reeves neo simply
doesn't emote ever all these years later
his infamously low-key one-word
catchphrase remains memorable
whoa but that is one can easily argue
the point of the character
luckily reeves has since found a
comfortable home in the excellent john
wick series where a subtle performance
as a grief-stricken terrifyingly skilled
protagonist makes a lot of sense
plus you're too amazed by the incredible
fight choreography to really care much
one way or the other
reeves is quite the philanthropist
although he doesn't like to draw
attention to this
regarding one of his charitable projects
reeves said in 2009
i have a private foundation that's been
running for five or six years and it
helps aid a couple of children's
hospitals in cancer research i don't
like to attach my name to it
i just let the foundation do what it
does in addition to his generosity
reeves is also shockingly private
largely shining the flashy celebrity
lifestyle
as a result of all this generosity and
humility reeves reputation has
drastically transformed in recent years
he's gone from being dismissed as a
moderately talented action star to a
beloved figure of hollywood
all this sudden adoration might seem a
bit much but it's not going anywhere
anytime soon the story of a man who's
been through so much only to remain a
generous
quiet person is just too wholesome for
the internet not to fawn over
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one